How's it going bros this is Pewdiepie
Yeah
You bros submitted over 100 pages of fan art
last week
I am announcing a new competition
by the end of this video so don't miss it
these are the winners
I am so excited to see what you bros have made.
You had over a week to create.
So, I expect some pretty cool stuff!
So...
Let's start!
*buffering*
What the fuck is this?
This is the most beautiful art I have ever seen in my life.
Ayy, boobs c:
No, this is a great idea. I'm so glad I came up with this.
"This is what happens when Poods smoke weed."
How the fuck do you know that?
Why do you bros want me to get a chronic disease?
What the fuck is this?
What...
Heeeeey!
Look at that!
*smooch* Beautiful!
That's stunning.
Why are my hands dicks?
That one's pretty cute!
Very kawaii!
*smooch*
Umm...
Last time I checked I'm not 84 years old.
Don't just fucking take a picture
and then put a fucking shitty photoshop filter on it
and say you drew it!
Woah, okay.
Very erotic.
If you look closer you can actually see that this photo is not photoshopped.
Man, you have a lot of detail, it's fucking amazing!
No.
Nooo!
Okay, that's pretty cool.
Is that me winning over Dylan the Hacker?
That's what's gonna happen Dylan.
Dylan: How DARE you?!
Heheeeey
Animeee.
HeHEhehey!
Oh god!
*laughs*
What the fuck?
ssss
Hey, this is pretty cool.
My eyebrows look like the mustache of Steve Harvey.
Well, at least you're honest.
Heeey, that's awesooome!
Very kawaii.
You think you're funny?
Ayy, this one's amazing!
This is 2011 PewDiePie, where I actually look fucking hot as shit.
*tap*
*harder tap*
Now, look at me now!
*another tap*
Pewds?
OUCH!
Oh my god!
This one looks real. That's amazing!
Hehe "Onebrofist man"
Wow.
You really captured my nose and my...
golden teeth.
Some of these are actually really talented.
I- I'm really impressed.
This one is not it. I'm sorry.
POODIEPIE SUCKZ!
Nohohohahaha!
EUGH
hahaha
Nohohooo
"For PewDiePie"
Ohhhh :>
Hello, hello, hello there.
Now we're talking.
Oh my god, this is getting too hot.
The fuck is this? XD
What. The hell...
am I looking at here?
Why did you draw hair on my feet?!
Dh-hahaha
notice me pewdiepie senpai
Nice ass. I can't tell if that's- that's my balls or my ass
but either way it's good.
You know? It's good, don't worry about it.
Aawwwhh.
*smooch*
yes
*another smooch*
We found it, guys.
Ooooooooooooooooooooh.
Aight.
*laughs*
We-
We've dabbled into furry section.
PewDiePie McConaughey
Now this...
That's muscle goals.
I love the one punch one.
ONE PUUUUUNCH!
No, I can do it.
ONE PUUUUUUUUUUUNCH!
Heeey, Gravity Falls!
Fuck, yeah!
That's awesome!
Woa, what the hell is this?
That's so cool...
Ok, that one's cool.
That one's fucking cool.
I don't know why you guys like Attack on the Titan so damn much.
Play-doh-Pie.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Thehe! SHh
Ahahahahaha
eughhshh
That's beautiful.
That's beautiful, man.
Wow.
Just...
Just wow.
Honestly.
What the fuck...
is this?
Hooly fuck.
What the ff- shh-
What the fucking...
She even has an ass tattoo.
oh man...
Ouuuh.
Hello!
Ohhh! Gets better!
Oh my god! That's me in fo- That totally looks like me!
What?
What. The. Fuck is this?
Oh, that's... creepy?
You sent me on a pregnant lady?
What the f-
*laughs*
Why am I a mermaid?
And why am I so into it? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
*wink*
Ayyy that's fucking awesome!
Bloodborne, baby!
Um...
I have two questions:
Why?
And why?
And please kill me.
"What's hiding in pewds' beard?"
"The entirety of Ikea"
"All the unmade PewDieCry videos"
*laughs*
"Edgar's discipline"
Yeah, that- that doesn't even exist.
Oh, for fuck's sake.
Why is there a T-rex?
And why do I have a vibrating buttplug?
"Zero deaths!"
Theheha
*inhale*
That's awesome.
Aww, that's so cool! They added like older series and refrences.
I love- I love stuff like this.
That's so cool.
"This took me like 5 minutes."
I'm surprised that took you 5 minutes.
I can do that in 5 seconds. Aight?
Now, this is just like... what the fuck is going on in your head?
Awwwh! So cute!!
Ooooh! That's fucking awesome!!
Hell yeah!
Thanks for not making me bald as well. I ap- I appreciate that.
*processing*
Oh, Poo-D-Pie!
Thahahaha!
ssssh
It took me a while.
I was like: why...?
"TIMMY!"
Heheha
*inhale*
What the... What?
"I ate pewdiepie, pewdiepie's socks."
Oh! Heh!
*inhale* hahahaha!
*inhale* haha *inhale*
haha *inhale*
Oh, that's good!
You're tryna tell me I have a big head?
Are you telling- Are you tryna tell me YouTube has gone to my head?
Ohhh.
Yayuh!
I look like Matthew McConaughey!
Fuck yeah!
Thehe!
That's fucking awesome.
That's so fucking cool!
Like- I like it.
"I'm sorry bros but I'm never going to shave this fabulous beard of mine."
"Nope. Never."
See? This is what I'm going for.
Oh my god.
Why would you...
Woaah! That's awesome!
Some of these are so cool!
Aww, the one with me and Marzia is so cute!
"Goddammit Pewds! Not again!"
Why does Edgar have a bigger- What the fuck?
Why the- What kinda tiny lil' nob thing is this?
Thss
What the hell are you trying to tell me, man?
Why is my left arm bigger than the other one?
What are you tryna tell me?!
Aaaaaaah!
Hehahaha!
"Heavy Rain. Press X to Edgar!"
Edgar!
Step out of my way! Jesus chri-
This is awesome!
Edgar!
What the fuck is this?!
Oh, it's Edgar!
*facepalm* hehahaha!
Beh- Oooh! That's cool!
Hey!
That's awesome!
And that's a bro- That's a brofist!
Woah!
These are awesome!
Dude! That's so cool!
I'mma save this.
Why- What's with all the ref- naen...
*laughs* It's 'cuz of the beard? Yeah.
Thsss
It's 'cuz of the beard.
Oh yes!
Is that a winner? Of course!
Before and after fabulizer.
Hehahaha!
Oh my god, there we go again!
Ouuuh, hallooo. What happened to yerr?
Undertale! That's awesome!
c;
I love it.
Woa! What the fuck?
*spits all over the screen*
Why do I look so vicious?
Hehehahaha
Awww, it's a lil' poodiepie bracelet!
That's awesome!
Tehahahahaha!
Oooh my goood!
That's soo cool!
That's so pretty!
Aww, Edgar and Maya <3
Thank you!
Jeez! We're getting to some really good ones.
Oh my god!
Jesus! That's so creepy!
Ehahahaha!
Saaaved! Ahahaha!
Yeah! Viking Pewds!
Fuck yeah!
Hehaha!
Woaaaaaah!
Thanks Yoga!
*laughs*
That's awesome!
Salad ass!
That's cool.
Zero deaths!
Bros! For fuck's sake! *saves*
What the sssss- fuck?
It's from the livestream!
*music plays*
Fucking badass!
It's fucking badass, man!
Hell yeah!
Awww, that's awesome!
Oh, it's all Undertale!
*laughs* That's so cool.
Look at Edgar and Maya.
PewDiePie the Pugrider
Fuck yeah!
Why am I naked?
Doesn't matter!
Aw, this person is awesome!
I've- I've seen this work before.
It's like a template of a PewDiePie...
Or- Or this is like a template of a fighting game.
The s- The animation of like the stuff. It's so cool!
"Subscribe and punch"
Hey! Let's make that happen!
Aaand we finish off with another amazing artwork.
Jesus Christ.
Bros, I'm blown away.
So funny, so talented, so awesome...
I'm really impressed and I- I love doing this type of videos with you because...
I don't know, it's cool to do something together and... uh...
It means a lot to me that you bros participate in these.
Uh, so thank you, to everyone who submitted.
The next challenge is going to be...
about my beard!
So as you bros seem to be so obsessed with it, go ahead!
Do you love it? Do you hate it? Roast my beard.
Are you #PewdsBeard or #PewdsShave?
The hashtag with more tweets will win.
The hashtag with more tweets will decide the fate of this beard.
Now, go.
Go forth, my children.
Tell the king! Tell him about the beard!
And as always, stay awesome bros!
*outro music*